الكل يقاطع المنتجات اللي بتدعم الصهاينه
لان المنتجات اقسم بالله بتاثر اقتصاديا
وماديا وبتاثر العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
الشركات واسرائيل يا جماعه الخير
المقاطعات لها اثر كثير ما حدش يفقد الشغف
انتم باقل باقل باقل امكانيات اللي هي
المقاطعه بتاثر كثير ما حدش يفق الشغف لا
اللي انتم بتعملوه باثر باثر وانشروا
الفيديو وخلوا صناع المحتوى ويرجعوا ثاني
وكرروا قاطعوا المنتجات بدعم اسرائيل
شيروا الفيديو لكل ناع المحتوى وخلي صناع
المحتوى يتكلم من اول جديد ويعيدوا الصيغه
من اول جديد يقاطعوا المنتجات اللي بتدعم
الصهاينه ماحدش فيكف الشغف تعملوه انتم في
المقاطعه باثر كثير جدا جدا جدا ما حد يف
الشغف وهذا اكثر شغله بتقدر تدعم فيها
قضيتنا انك انت تقاطع المنتجات اللي بتدعم
الها